un día de la independencia marcado por
la guerra la misma jornada en que
ucrania conmemora el 31 aniversario de
su independencia de la unión soviética
se cumplen también los seis meses del
inicio de la invasión rusa el presidente
de volodymyr selenski condecoró con la
medalla de la estrella dorada a varios
miembros del ejército mientras
familiares de soldados caídos recogieron
el homenaje en su honor coche por ya
cuatro vamos a tener saunas y ya me
gustaría agradecerles por nuestra
independencia medio año de una guerra
violenta a gran escala ocho años de la
heroica defensa de nuestro país durante
la guerra en el donbass una lucha
generacional por ucrania
helens quien estuvo acompañado del
primer ministro británico boris johnson
quien arremetió contra el presidente
ruso vladimir putin
el pueblo de ucrania está pagando con su
sangre y es por eso que sabemos que
debemos mantener el rumbo si putin
tuviera éxito ningún país en el
perímetro de rusia estaría a salvo
el mandatario ucraniano acudió horas
antes junto a la primera dama al
monasterio de las cúpulas doradas de
sanmiguel de kiev donde recordó a los
soldados caídos en el conflicto contra
rusia previamente había instado a luchar
por ucrania hasta el final
novak que es para nosotros el fin de la
guerra solíamos decir paz ahora decimos
victoria no buscaremos un entendimiento
mutuo con un terrorista aunque
entendemos el idioma ruso que vinieron a
defenderlas
[Música]
aunque la jornada solía estar marcada de
un gran desfile militar este año los
eventos han sido cancelados por miedo a
ataques tras días de advertencias de que
rusia podría bombardear la capital
durante las conmemoraciones quien se
encuentra en una relativa calma mientras
en otras partes del territorio como en
done jets bajo bombardeos lo más crudo
de la guerra continúa